un hecho sin precedentes la elección de
Joaquín jeffreys como líder de los
demócratas en la cámara de
representantes estadounidense Esta es la
primera vez que llega a este cargo una
afroamericano
esperamos encontrar oportunidades para
asociarnos con los republicanos y
trabajar con ellos siempre que sea
posible
pero también nos supondremos al
extremismo siempre que sea necesario
amamos este país amamos nuestra
democracia este abogado de 52 años
graduado con honores de la facultad de
derecho de la Universidad de Nueva York
representa la diversidad de los votantes
del partido y abre la puerta a un relevo
generacional en su cúpula tras la
renuncia de Nancy pelosi jeffreys
aprovechó para agradecerle por sus años
como presidenta de la cámara baja
quiere transmitirme agradecimiento a la
presidenta Nancy pelosi una horadora
extraordinaria para los tiempos que
corren que ha aportado tanto a tantos
durante un período de tiempo tan
significativo
El mundo es mejor gracias al increíble
liderazgo de la presidenta Nancy pelosi
el congresista quien repite por quinta
vez pertenece al octavo distrito de
Nueva York comprende gran parte de
Brooklyn Queens ha estado en el grupo de
los demócratas que aprobaron las grandes
iniciativas de Joe biden para la
recuperación económica como el plan de
rescate estadounidense tras la pandemia
de Kobe 19 la ley de inversión de
infraestructura y la de reducción de la
inflación para la siguiente legislatura
también fue elegida Katherine Clark como
número 2 de la bancada del partido